[Música]
l
ah
[Música]
abuelita
tienes esos ojos tan grandes
[Música]
abuelita
porque tiene esas orejas tan grandes
[Música]
abuelita
porque tienes esa boca tan grande acá
esta parte acá el momento en que
sobreviene la voz truculenta y feroz
despojada de todo el engaño de del lobo
si es esa parte que todos conocemos la
que esperamos verdad si este qué hubiera
pasado si al logo se le ocurre decir
para contarte mejor
y la historia hubiera sido otra verdad
pero tranquilos porque porque en
realidad sobrevive la historia del lobo
que se comió a la abuelita se come a la
caperucita
y además la historia remixada que
aparece un leñador para tranquilidad de
algunos que son como que se impresionan
para tranquilidad de algunos que que le
abre la panza el lobo y sale venta
la abuelita intacta la caperucita y
encima le pasa de prestar a oirán los
cabritos eso bueno no importa la
cuestión es que el lobo se cae al río y
se va para nunca más volver no sobrevive
la historia de esa están tranquilos
verdad
ahora bien
ustedes me preguntan
mentira
que tiene esa boca tan grande
yo que no soy caperucita no soy la
abuelita no soy el lobo disfrazado de
abuelita no soy el leñador
soy solo vos
y voces
para resucitar historias
yo me animo a decirte
para contarte mejor
y sí
y me animo a de 7 para seguir contando
te la historia de esos de esos lobos de
esos lobos que andan acechando por allí
escribiendo los million ardides para
colarse y mimetizarse y esas caperucitas
que que modernos así valientes andan
tiñendo las caperuzas de
y reclamos más allá de todo género y de
toda edad y acá estamos los cuenteros
acá estamos poniéndole la voz
acá estamos tratando de resucitar las
historias con la boca bien grande acá
estamos tratando de abrir el abanico de
estos escenarios tan circulares como la
vida misma
y de eso se trata lo que quiero charlar
con ustedes
de esta vida de lo que somos nosotros
porque nosotros somos la sumatoria de un
montón de vidas de un montón de
historias si uno mira para atrás vas
viendo que se van acumulando historias
hacia atrás y nos encontramos con un
puñado de hombres y mujeres en la época
de las cavernas en torno a un fogón
contándose el día para que para cargarlo
de sentido
contándose los a mares los decides los
sentires de ese día y vale la pena como
no claro que vale la pena y acá estamos
nosotros cargando de sentido este
momento
y pienso en mi mamá
y pienso la anécdota de mi mamá es a la
que me contaba una y otra vez y yo decía
para que me la cuenta otra vez
ya mi 53 digo para ser contada
mi mamá
en su segundo grado
en ese momento escolar donde los
estudiantes se exponen al ciento por mil
o los exponen
bien mi mamá que me contaba que tenían
que representar el alfabeto y cada
alumno tenía una letra y cada letra un
versito y que tenían que aprenderlo muy
bien a fuerza de sudor y lágrimas'
repita repita repita no sea cosa que le
falte una coma o un punto sí señor
y qué letra le tocó a mi mamá
la h
imagínense
ni siquiera
se atrevió a completar con el abrazo de
la mirada ese círculo penoso
con el otro
de allá del otro lado ni siquiera se
atrevió a eso
y pienso que yo también soy resultante
de esa historia de silenciamiento porque
de que tengo uso de razón así de
chiquitita yo contaba cuentos para
adentro ustedes conocen los cuentos de
semáforo de verdad pregunto conocen los
cuentos de semáforo no miren mi papá me
llevaba en la chata por la avenida
marcelo t de alvear que une el barrio
banda norte en río cuarto con el centro
y había en esa época un solo semáforo y
yo chiquitita como era pensaba que se
ponga rojo que se ponga rojo que se
ponga rojo
cuando el semáforo se ponía rojo yo
decía para adentro en silencio por
supuesto cuento de semáforo
y me inventaba uno que durara un rojo y
el colorín colorado coincidía justo
cuando
el colorado del semáforo desaparecía me
salían de lindos
pero a la vez a la vez sentía que había
un foso con cocodrilos
que alejaban que alejaban un montón de
pájaros que querían al aletear ya ni dar
acá
y sentía que había nudos marineros
que tejían soledades y silencios y crecí
contando cuentos para adentro cuentos
para adentro cuentos para adentro
cuentos para adentro y fue la h ricarte
y fui portador
a mis 12 años mi hermana alejandra un
poquito más grande que yo dijo quien
quiere escuchar los tres pelos del
los tres pelos del giramos una
montonera de hermanos y se armó un
revuelo universal y ahí y ahí yo no
sabía de qué se trataba y ahí
y ahí se produjo un momento bisagra
y ahí fue cuando mi hermana
y empezó a contar para fuera
[Música]
y cuando empezó a contar para afuera
pese a sentir como un
como un aleteo por dentro y empecé a
sentir que que se producía el abrazo de
la mirada que construíamos imágenes
fantásticas y empecé a sentir que el que
mengua leche
que mengua dicha y era grave porque no
había retorno no no no había modo de
volver de esa sensación y dije para
charlar
se necesitan dos necesito un oído
cautivo
necesito pobre mi sobrinito el más días
pobres
ahí nomás lo invite al parque sarmiento
creo que hice un surco porque lo llevé y
lo traje lo llevé y lo traje lo llevé y
otras tantas veces
y el eco de mi voz contando cuentos para
afuera
fue dejando lugar para que esos pájaros
hagan nidos
pongan huevos y se multipliquen y para
que esas redes sean redes de miradas de
carcajadas de imágenes
y estuvo bueno
ciao cocodrilos y hay citó no más
cuando crecí me di cuenta que
que era cuestión de tomar una decisión
y era cuestión de elegir elegir elegir
elegir y uno elige lo que ya saboreó uno
elige desde el recuerdo uno elige
enfocando el placer
yo soy iris maría
horno de barro
yo soy mamá esposa maestra de alma
narradora oral comunitaria
yo desde hace décadas decidí
decidí luchar para que las historias no
mueran contando de adentro hacia afuera
en comunidad
decidí enarbolar la estética de la
palabra es a la que enaltece la que
eleva la que mancilla
elegí
elegí el concepto de oralización
responsable ese que nos regala alejandra
oliver maestra de maestros narradora
cordobesa para hacerme cargo de lo que
digo
elegí formarme preservando estilo
potenciando aptitud de la mano de
alejandra oliver
y el hijo
dijo crear un espacio popular gratuito
comunitario que de enero a enero
funcione sin ningún derecho admisión
todo el mundo puede pasar me de paz se
vea escuche cuente
elijo fundar una rueda cuentera una
rueda que funciona en un lugar
determinado a una hora determinada para
que venga el que quiera aquí
a contarse historias a recitarse poemas
a narrar se la vida a leer esa carta del
arco de la abuela o escuchar que no es
poco
una rueda cuentera que de enero a de
enero funcione en un lugar determinado y
que uno abra la puerta y esperes
y que cuando venga el segundo le diga
salvaste la rueda
pasa
y cuantos vienen no se serán diez quince
veinte no lo sé salvas de la rueda pasa
y la y la palabra empieza a circular a
circular a una hora ay se encajó uno se
quedó encajado en el índice yo quería
contarles algo pero escúchenme yo acá
esperen un poquito bisagra de palabra no
se puede producir un bache en esa rueda
co entera rápido alguien salva ese
momento con un poema una copla una
retahíla un bocadito de palabra y rueda
la palabra y rueda y rueda en la rueda
cuentera y rueda una hora de reloj
para que sobrevenga el aplauso
y ahí
durante una hora nos miramos con la
palabra porque si quiere el verano
cuando no hay una sede a dónde ir venga
a la casa de venga el techo de cielo de
quiero invitarlos
job
quiero invitarlos quiero quiero que
piensen en este espacio en este garaje
que tienes ahí desocupado en ese espacio
que te presta el gremio o la vecinal en
este galpón citó que te deja ahí
arrumbado
quiero invitarte en wally charter
ya que en wally eches
la rueda cuente da no es un grupo es un
espacio de encuentro quiero invitarte a
que en el paraje en el pueblo en la
ciudad donde quieras que estés con boc
es una hora con la frecuencia que
quieras para que la palabra ruede porque
si sin corsé vení en walt y chad en
wallis a los otros a esos y nos pidas un
beso de un príncipe que te desencante y
que te saque de ese igual dicho no ni se
te ocurra ir a buscar la pluma de ese
pájaro extraño ni los tres pelos de s
obra s obró espantoso que está cruzando
los siete arroyos de ninguna manera
igual y chad nos pidas antídotos
mira si después
después de que todos ustedes han
fundados ruedas cuenteras nos volvemos a
encontrar
y se me ocurre preguntarle algo como
y tienen esa boca tan grande y ustedes
me respondan para
porque sólo hacen falta dos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah